Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Rhett.
And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are talking about ch-ch-ch-changes.
Yeah, we asked you ...
Changing your mind.
We asked you, where we
ask these questions,
which is Twitter, on the Mythical account,
to tell us a time that you
changed your perspective on something.
Could be small like a food preference,
could be something big like
a major belief and why.
And we got a lot of responses.
Yeah, I'm excited about
talking about this.
Yank in your laptop here so
we can look at some responses,
but, you know we wanted to
talk about this because,
and kind of mission accomplished
as far as I'm concerned here,
because we were hoping
that it would just be
a refreshing sensation
of people sharing how
they changed their mind.
And I don't know, there's a
humility associated with saying,
"I once thought this."
And even if it's a minor preference,
"But now I think this,
"I disagree with my former
self about this thing,
"big or small."
It's something to celebrate
in this day and age
when people just dig in and
there's no conversations.
And not that this conversation
is gonna get political,
necessarily.
I mean, we got some lighthearted stuff and
some heavier stuff, but it
really doesn't get into,
'cause we, you know, we
talk about those things
in other, well, there's one thing
that kind of gets a
little political in this,
but anyway, one of the reasons
I was so excited about talking about this
is all the things that you just said.
But also I think that, you know,
there's a little bit of a
selfish, a self-interest in this,
which is like, you know,
in ways that we have
shared on this podcast
we've changed our minds.
And I'm kind of fascinated
with the reasons why
people change their mind.
Because I think a lot of times
it's not the reason that
you state, you know?
And there's just all kinds of factors.
And I think we got some really
honest, honest responses
and I'm just fascinated
with the concept of
perspective change and what leads to it.
And like you said, I just
think it's so timely,
because it seems that
there's so many people
spending more of their energy
attempting to change other people's minds
in ways that we haven't really seen before
in like discourse, right?
I was talking to Jesse the other day
and I was like, you know,
she hates going on Facebook,
because Facebook has
become a place where you
kinda just say, "This is who
I am, this is what I believe."
And then argue with people
who differ with you.
You know, I think at
first it was kind of like,
"Hey, I'm having a baby."
Or, "Look at what I did with my friends."
And then it would be like, okay,
maybe once every four years
during the presidential
election people might start
like saying what they
stood for or whatever.
But now it's like a really high percentage
of the dialogue is just people
arguing with each other.
But no one's actually moving
on anything, like you said,
it's just people continuing to polarize
and kind of align themselves
with other people who all agree with them.
And it's just, there's
no end in sight, right?
It's discouraging.
Yeah. I mean, so we're making a choice
to not celebrate people who've said,
"I changed someone else's mind."
Yeah, right.
"But I changed my own mind."
And to see the things that lead
to people changing their minds.
And let me just say, of all,
we read through almost all the responses,
Kiko definitely read
through all the responses.
None of them said,
"I used to think this
and I changed my mind
"because someone on
Facebook argued with me."
That didn't happen in any one of these.
Nobody said that.
Right, yeah, so let's get into this.
I think that we can start with Aleda.
@aleda25543612.
There's a lot of those already taken.
Wow, there's a lot of Aleda's out there.
250, 2,554,000.
Nope, 25 million.
There's 25 million.
Is that a phone number?
Can we put commas in
your username so we know
what the number actually is?
Let's call that number
and see if she answers.
Oh, yeah, it's not a phone number?
No, it's one, two, it's one less digit.
We can probably figure it out.
Yeah.
All right,
we're calling an audible.
This episode is now
devoted entirely to ...
Trying to get in touch with Aleda.
She responded to us at Mythical.
"I absolutely hate the
sound of children singing."
So you thought we were
gonna start all serious.
No, we're not.
It's gonna take us a
while to get through it.
I don't know, I think
this is serious to her.
She says, "I used to love it,
"but then all those
singing idol shows came out
"and now it's like
fingernails on a chalkboard.
"P.S. I'm an elementary school teacher."
Wow.
So I wonder if it's the
culture of amateur singing
in general that maybe inspired a change
in the youth that then she
experienced personally?
Or is it just the idea of seeing so many,
I mean, how old do you have to be to be,
you got to be like 13
to be on American Idol.
Yeah, I think what she
means is that, you know,
she's surrounded by these
elementary school kids
who were like singing in
chorus and stuff like that.
And it's what wasn't necessarily
pro by any means or
splendid, but still cute,
lost all of its luster
to the point that she
actually said, "You know what?
"I don't like kids singing anymore."
Oh, I hate it, I hate the
sound of children singing.
"You ruined it for me."
Television idol, singing
idol shows ruined it for her,
but she made a decision.
She's like, "You know what?"
Or, sometimes you come to
grips with how you've changed
and you just, and so that's kind of like
a backdoor decision, right?
"Well, I don't like this
anymore and I'm okay with it."
So the decision is owning it.
Though it would make her life easier
being an elementary school teacher
if she would find a way to like it.
Well, she's not, she's not the choral.
She didn't say that, but if she said,
"I am an elementary
school chorus teacher."
Yeah, it would be tough.
We would be outing her
right now, first of all.
Well, she kind of outed
herself on Twitter.
This makes me think of something.
But it's not something you're supposed to,
it's something you're supposed to like.
So I do applaud her in
saying, "It is a preference."
But she's standing by it.
This is what I'm getting at is,
I actually recently rediscovered
how much I do like the
sound of children singing,
and this sounds weird, I
understand, but let me just ...
You talking about Christmas
boys' choir situation?
I'm talking about Moonrise Kingdom,
which I watched recently with the family.
Me and Jesse and Shepherd watched it.
And I'm beginning to really
kind of understand Shepherd
and understand the kinds of
things that he will like.
And so I was like,
"Shepherd, I have a movie
that I want you to watch,
"that I know you are going to like."
Of course this is Wes
Anderson's Moonrise Kingdom.
And right at the beginning,
I kind of look at him
and he was just seeing the
way things were unfolding
and the way things were being described.
And he just had this
little smile on his face.
And then he just kept looking
at me and he was just like, "I love this."
He was like, "This is the kind
of movie that I really like."
And he wasn't just saying that
because I had planted the
thought in his mind, but anyway.
Great movie.
It's a great movie,
and I feel kind of bad
about how much I didn't ...
I loved it, I really liked it
when I watched it in the theater.
But I didn't realize that
this might be my favorite
Wes Anderson movie.
Oh really?
Like it wasn't in like
the top three for me,
but I feel like it is now.
Anyway, lots of boys' choir.
You changed your mind about it.
Lots of boys' choir,
which I've always kind of liked
the sound of like a boys' choir.
I've just thought that it's got this
sort of angelic sound to it,
but like the way that he
uses that music in the movie.
There's a time and a place.
It's so good.
It's just so good.
So I like the sound of children singing.
Well, you like the sound of
professional children singing.
Yeah, yeah, right, not amateurs.
Yeah.
Professional children.
Kyna is the name of the next
respondent @therealkhaki.
"I started drinking my coffee black
"over the past couple of years.
"It's important to assert
dominance over beverages.
"#EarBiscuits."
Wow, there's a lot to unpack here, Kyna.
Because, man.
The way that I kind of interpret this is
I totally relate with the idea
that there's something more respectable,
and I'm not saying this is true.
I'm saying I have this
perception that lives
within my mind that there's
something more respectable
about drinking coffee black,
that it's ultimately better.
Like if you had to like rank five people
and there was a person
who put a bunch of sugar
and a bunch of cream in their coffee
on one end of the spectrum,
and there was a person who
drank their coffee black
on the other end of the spectrum.
I would respect the person
who drank their coffee black.
And I don't exactly know
why that's the case.
It's more hardcore.
It's like it implies a toughness
Because there's something
to protect yourself
from when it comes to coffee.
Because coffee is always bitter.
It's an acquired taste.
Yeah, when you add cream or sugar to it,
as you take a sip of
your cream-laden coffee.
Yeah, we'll get to that in a second.
Any sugar in there?
No sugar, but ...
I'm a no sugar.
I'm a but cream man.
A butt cream man?
I use butt cream as well.
But every morning, every single morning,
you know what, I'm realizing this.
When I make my coffee
and it's going down into my mug
and then I go over to the fridge
and I reach for the half-and-half,
I have a pang of guilt
to this day because, and because
of this sentiment of it's,
you know, you're a bad-ass
if you can drink it black.
And here I am, you know,
it's like pouring defeat into my coffee.
Yeah, okay, I have a theory about this.
I think there's two
things going on, right?
So the legitimate side
of the migration from
a lot of sugar and a lot
of cream in your coffee
to black coffee
is a legitimate scientific
process that happens
with things that are an
acquired taste, right?
So it's like, "Oh, I
don't really like alcohol.
"Oh, but you know what?
"I had a wine cooler and
now I drink just white wine.
"Oh, I'll drink just a white wine.
"Well, you know what?
"I tried a red, I tried a
Pinot Noir at this party
"and it was pretty good."
And then you work your way up
and the next thing you know
you're just putting back
like 20 year aged scotch.
You know what I'm saying?
That's a scientific process of
your literal face and mouth
adjusting to an acquired taste.
And I think the same
thing happens with coffee.
So, there's an achievement.
Right.
You know, it's kind of
like winning at something.
If you want to look at it that way.
It's almost like there's
a purity of experience,
especially when it comes to good coffee.
That's why when you go to
a place like Intelligentsia
and they've got like, you
know, an $8 pour over coffee
and you ask for cream in it,
they look at you with
disdain because they're like,
"You're not, you're actually taking ..."
"You're not woke."
"Yeah, well, you're not
getting the experience
"that was intended by the
person who made this coffee.
"You're taking the edge off of something
"that doesn't need the edge
off, this isn't Folgers."
So I respect that.
But I also feel like if you
like cream in your coffee
more than you like black
coffee that trumps this,
if you're not there yet or
you don't want to go there,
listen, I tried for like
a year to do black coffee
and I was, you know, I
had multiple motivations.
One was like, "Okay, it's more healthy."
'Cause there's no, you know,
there's less calories in there
if it's just coffee, but
also it's more bad-ass.
But then I just came to the conclusion
I'm not gonna try anymore.
And then during the pandemic
I've become what I would
call a Cafe-Au-Lait-man.
I mean, I'm basically ...
You got that extra time to whip it up.
I'm just saying that I'm about 50% milk,
50% of coffee if I can be.
And you know what?
I love everything about it.
So you changed your mind
and I thought I had too,
but I clearly haven't
fully changed my mind
to accept my preference
and not judge myself.
I think that, you know, there seems to be
a tinge of pride in her post.
"It's important to assert
dominance over beverages."
Well, I think what she is doing ...
She might have been baiting you,
'cause I think this is
something that you ...
Listen, she's obviously saying something
slightly tongue in cheek,
but I think it is reflective of
that sort of cultural expectation
of drinking black coffee
being more respectable.
Which incidentally we've paired
this with another question.
I'm sorry, before you do,
I did want to acknowledge
that like when I was thinking
of the ways that I've changed
my mind over the years,
like I made a decision
to start drinking coffee
in college because it's
like, "What am I missing?"
And is it, you know,
"Is this gonna be helpful
to keep me awake?"
And you know, so I actually, I
changed my mind about coffee.
You felt like you were becoming a, me too,
we both started drinking
coffee in college.
And I think many people do,
because you're becoming
an independent adult
and you're like, "This is what adults do."
It's the same reason a lot of
people start drinking alcohol
and don't like it at first.
I don't think that that
social pressure is all bad
or even bad at all.
I think it's just a natural part of life.
And you actually, sometimes
social pressure to mature
and become an adult and
actually go through the process
of acquiring a taste.
There's some people who are like,
"Okay, the whole acquired
taste thing is just bullshit,
"because what you guys are saying is
"that you don't really like it
"but you're making yourself like it.
"So I'm never going down that."
But there's a reward at the end of
an acquired taste journey.
Yeah, someone else made
a post about whiskey.
Exactly.
It's a super common process.
I don't think that's all bad,
but there is a negative element to it,
which you're kind of getting
at with judging yourself
in the midst of the process, right?
Mm-hmm.
And that's where I think that
Arshia, mythical Zan Scaz,
on Twitter is kind of
tapped into something.
And this is what they have
changed their behavior about,
changed their mind about.
"My behavior, I'm a
textbook people-pleaser,
"a very anxious person and
I have abandonment issues.
"All my life I've tried
never to say no to someone,
"tried to fit into social
norms and be the ideal person.
"Now after therapy,
"I prioritize myself
and my mental health."
Thank you for sharing
this, Arsha or Arshia.
This is by far the most
common response that we got
to our particular post was, you know,
related to the topic of ...
Another way to put it is realizing
that your life is your own.
And if you start to trace the motives
behind the decisions you're making,
if you start pulling on those strings
and they go out to other people
or to just other ideas
outside of yourself,
I think it can lead to problems, right?
Well, it is an interesting balance, right?
Because I do believe that
social pressure in general,
there's a reason that
social pressure exists
and there's a positive reason, right?
We are a collective organism
whether we like it or not
and whether Facebook seems
to reflect that or not,
we are members of a community,
we're members of a collective
and there's a lot of aspects of
our personalities and our biology
that are kind of tuned
towards us getting along
in the context of a group.
That's where like the concept of shame,
like the concept of shame
is not intrinsically bad
from a biological perspective.
It comes from something
that was actually useful,
but in the modern world it's mostly toxic
in the way that we experience it, right?
And apply it.
I mean, yeah.
So it does bear saying that
there are certain things
that no one should get away with
just because it's their prerogative.
Right.
There's a whole litany of those things.
Yeah.
But there are, you know,
if you're a well-meaning person
with a certain level of
humility that, you know,
starts to understand themselves,
like this person is saying
through therapy and understanding
that you've deprioritized
yourself to the point that
the fact that it's your life
is not entering the decision matrix.
Right, because when you make decisions
that are about your health,
prioritizing your mental health
and making you a better person,
you actually become a better
member of the collective.
And you can, so you can,
it's a win-win situation
when you understand yourself, right?
And so I definitely, listen,
I so relate to this,
especially, I mean, the part about
you know, being a people-pleaser,
there's things that I
continue to unpack in therapy
about just, you know, my personality
and why my personality is what it is,
but I am a people- pleaser.
It's difficult to say no,
I do have this sort of idea
of what is expected of me.
And also a lot of times I
evaluate the things that I'm doing
in the context of how I will
be perceived about them.
And I have to continually
catch myself doing that
and then be like, "Hold
on, are you doing this?
"You're doing this for a bad
sort of like social reason
"so you you'll be accepted
"or people will perceive
you in a certain way,
"or are you actually
thinking about yourself
"and what you actually like
"or what would be good for you?"
You don't want to prioritize
yourself selfishly
so that then it takes advantage of people,
because that's a whole different,
that's a completely
different concept, right?
This is just about realizing when
you don't need to be making a decision,
because someone else's preference
or someone else's perception is
the thing that's driving you primarily.
Yeah, you can become enslaved
to other people's
expectations and opinions.
Yeah.
And you can die inside.
And, but realizing that opens the door
to changing your mind, you know?
It's, you know, going back
to the beginning, you know,
I think about the phrase of,
it's like when, if somebody says something
that makes you change your mind,
I was thinking about the phrase,
if you do want to say back to
them, "You changed my mind."
And just the idea that, well, you know,
sometimes you can realize
that your mind has changed.
You can realize that
someone has had an influence
over you and that it
could be a true statement,
"You changed my mind."
But it seems like the more
healthy disposition and approach
is to say, "You know what?
"I am the one who changes my mind.
"I can choose whether I
allow someone's influence."
Or, you know, not just
a person, an experience,
whatever the case may be to influence me.
But it's, you know,
giving someone the power,
it's giving somebody power
over you if you're saying,
you know, and maybe it's semantics,
but saying, "You changed my mind."
Versus ...
I think it's important.
... "You helped me change my mind,
"but I'm in charge."
Again, this is my life.
The decisions that I make,
the perspectives that I have,
the actions that I take, you know,
I'm ultimately culpable for
those, you just can't say,
"Well, somebody told me to do it."
Well, therapy's the
perfect example, right?
Like that's why good
therapists and most therapists
don't give advice
and they don't tell you
what you should think.
They ask questions and they lead you
through a process of self discovery,
because they understand that first of all,
it ain't gonna last if it's not
a personal motivated change.
And second of all, it's like
they don't have the power to do it.
Like you don't really have the power to
change someone's mind.
And this is coming from a person
who tries to be persuasive,
has a very sort of, "I'm out
to change people's minds"
natural disposition that I
have to kind of keep in check.
Just reminding myself that
people don't change their mind
because of those kinds of things.
Now, before we move on,
we're gonna take short break in a second,
but I do just want to, a related thing,
just because I was thinking about it
when we were talking about shame
and like changing people's minds
and social media and all
that stuff, is Brené Brown.
I was listening to her recently
and she was talking about how shame
is not a good tool for social change.
In other words, the way
to get someone to realize
that what they think is wrong,
if that's what your goal is
shame is not a great motivator.
It actually doesn't do a lot
to change people's minds.
It just makes them feel shameful,
which then kind of, shame
usually leads to worse behavior,
not like actual changing
and good behavior,
but it seems that that's
something that happens
on both sides of the,
and I don't like to do the
whole both sides thing,
but one of the things I've observed like
as our country has gotten
even more polarized this year
than it ever was in a
time when it seemed like
we had a great opportunity
to kind of come together,
we got more polarized.
Both sides tend to point out
things about the other side,
mischaracterize things
about the other side.
And in the process, the goal is like,
"I'm shaming you because you think this,
"or you believe this or
you've identified in this way.
"And that is shameful."
It might be true that it's shameful.
There are behaviors that are shameful.
There are things that you can say and do
and things that you can believe
that are truly shameful,
but shaming someone about
them doesn't tend to
be a great way to change
their minds about them.
Just a sidebar there.
We got more questions,
but we also have a Pop
Socket to tell you about.
We've got multiple Pop Sockets,
but the one that we ...
Is your phone falling off of your hand?
Well, you need a Pop Socket.
This one has the GMM logo.
Available at Mythical.com.
There's also like a Feel
Good Mythical Morning.
Yeah, there is.
And another one, maybe a Mythical one?
Are you looking for another
way to fidget with your phone?
You're gonna want one of these.
A Mythical Pop Socket
available at Mythical.com.
Oh, yeah.
Pop it, socket.
Pop it, no, this is not a bop it ad.
I like this one.
Jade Marie posted,
"I used to say that I
hated all country music
"when I really just hated the uncle
"who would always listen to country music.
"No one wanted to hear
that opinion though."
Yeah, again, this is a ...
We did.
... this is a case.
This is a case of your perception on,
your perspective of
something is influenced
by a relationship in a negative way.
Yeah, I get it.
I mean, didn't you, you told me ...
But then you realize
you're making a decision.
You told me a story, you
may have told them the story
about how you made a
decision to not like music
because your stepsister liked music.
Yeah, when I was like in
grade school, I don't know.
You know, it was just,
it's not that we hated each
other, but there was this ...
She was your stepsister.
Stepsister, there was this
implied, I mean, we would argue
we had to share a bathroom, you know?
I didn't ...
Let's see, she was probably, you know ...
She was like a teenager.
At least six, you know,
maybe five years older than me, you know?
And she, she was, she was not,
she was just acting on teenage instinct.
Well, you were thrust
into each other's lives
at a really interesting time, right?
Yeah, so I was like, "You know what?
"I'm not gonna like
anything that she likes."
Including music, and all music.
Yeah.
It wasn't a genre.
It was just like music as a thing.
There was definitely, I'm sure
that that was a statement.
"I don't like music."
I mean, now music is
one of my top passions.
Right.
But, so there was a
point when it was like,
I think once we started,
once I started going over
to friends' homes and like,
"Oh, they're really enjoying music.
"I got to change my mind
about this, or I'm gonna be,
"I'm gonna check-out of the zeitgeist."
I think that those were the
terms I used as a third grader.
Yeah, zeitgeist.
It's like, "Man, I
gotta get this new tape.
"I gotta start listening to tapes."
Well, and specifically ...
I changed my mind, I'm proud
to say I do like music now.
A lot of people don't like country music
because of the association.
And, you know, whatever you
associate that with, right?
If it's the parts about the
South that embarrass you,
which there are parts about everywhere
that embarrass everyone who's from them.
And if it feels like ...
Maybe it's just the
twangy earnestness of it.
But I'm saying that it represents
or is associated with a distillation
of the things that
embarrass you about a place.
There's a lot of people,
we grew up with a lot
of people who are like,
"I think that country
music isn't sophisticated
"so I'm going to not like it."
And sometimes you don't
even give it a chance.
Now I will say, I went through a phase,
now we always liked country music,
but we always liked sort
of classic country music.
And there were a few
sort of modern artists.
Like I went, I was
really into Garth Brooks
in the early '90s.
I did not follow him into
the Chris Gaines era, okay?
I'm proud to say that I didn't do that.
Not because it wasn't country,
just because it was horrible.
But I think that, and
then as an adult, like,
even like right after
Jesse and I got married,
we went through a couple of years phase
where we would listen
to like 94.7 in Raleigh,
like the modern country.
Modern country.
And it was so positive and so sweet
that there was this
sort of like young love,
married, starting a family
kind of vibe that country music
sort of just un-ironically
embraces that we liked.
Now when we go back,
I don't listen to much modern
country at all right now.
Yeah.
I mean, I love Jason Isbell
and Sturgill Simpson,
but they don't really,
they're not considered country
by a lot of the country people.
But when we go back to North Carolina
one of the things that I do as a habit is
we listen to local country radio
whenever we drive in the car
just to like kind of
just dip in completely.
And it's difficult for me
to take, I gotta be honest.
Yeah.
It's pretty difficult.
But like eradicating and writing off
an entire genre of all
country music, or, you know
someone made the same post,
but about electronic music,
and then started, described how they
began to understand the
craftsmanship around it.
And they changed their mind about the,
well, true music has to be created
with actual like acoustic instruments.
Yeah.
Or, you know, like playable instruments.
And even that, I don't know,
they say the dichotomy a
little bit differently,
because you would feel,
sense and things like that
Yeah, a big boomer perspective,
like the way boomers think about rap,
like, you know, I've heard many boomers
talk about rap as if rap
doesn't take any talent, right?
Like, "Oh, these guys
are just standing there,
"and like go see him in concert.
"There's just music playing
and they're walking around."
Right.
I think we have an appreciation for it,
because we've tried to do
it in parody form, you know?
We've tried to be like,
"All right, we're gonna do this rap."
And when you recognize how hard
it is to make it sound good
or make it sound anywhere close to what
a professional would do,
you start realizing that this is,
same thing with like,
I've always had this thing about poetry,
which is like, "Okay, so
what's the deal with poetry?
"Especially poetry that doesn't rhyme."
You know what I mean?
It just, yeah.
there's a couple of, a smattering of words
and a random indention,
and then another smattering of words,
then it's over.
I've lived long enough to know
that if I were really to dive
into the world of poetry,
I would be like, "I see
what makes a good poet."
I gotta say, I'm an
unsophisticated country boy
from North Carolina in a lot of ways.
And one of those ways
is that my favorite poet
is Shel Silverstein, right?
Happy to say it, but I'm
sure that if I understood
like the reality of what
makes Emily Dickinson good
that I would be like,
"Oh, this isn't just something
that somebody determined.
"Like there's actually a reason for this.
"And I couldn't do it.
"I couldn't just start writing things."
Everybody thinks that they
can write poetry, right?
Yeah.
But that's not how it
works, it's more complex.
I think that's all I have
to say about country music.
John Mueller gets, you know,
gets really honest here.
In fact, begins to post with,
"Honestly, y'all ...
The way he changed his mind
was related to Black Lives Matter.
He says, "Honestly,
y'all, Black Lives Matter.
"I was one of those dumb people
who got mad at Kaepernick."
Kaepernick.
I'm gonna say that wrong.
When I see it, I'm like,
"I'm gonna say it wrong."
Well, you did.
"... Kaepernick
"about his protest, but what
happened throughout last year
"really galvanized a 180
degree change for me.
"Hat tip to Michael Che Matters
and Dave Chappelle as well."
Hmm.
Yeah, again.
Thanks John, for sharing that.
Yeah, thanks for being
honest and vulnerable,
you know, publicly.
It's not something that happens
a lot, especially, you know
you don't hear it a whole lot from
white guys who say y'all, you know?
That this is something that
they changed their minds about.
So thanks for doing that.
I think that, you know,
we feel like we can speak
with some authority on this issue,
because we are white boys
who grew up in the South
and had perspective
on these things that we don't think
it was really based in
reality and was ultimately,
could ultimately be
described as racist, right?
Not in your classic, external
explicit expressions of racism
that you'd see in like a
movie about the deep South,
but more this, this is
something that is in the fabric
of the way that we think
and we see the world
that ultimately is rooted in this idea
that whiteness is the standard
and whiteness is normal.
And it's, you know, it's taken
years to deconstruct that,
deconstruct that and to see all the places
that it impacted and all the ways
that it impacted our thinking.
I mean, I talked a little bit about this
in my letter to a white man that I wrote.
A lot about it.
That was the point of it.
Yeah, that was the point, was
to talk to my former self.
But I mean, in general, when you say,
"I changed my mind about blank."
But then specifically if it's
I changed my mind about systemic racism
and, or the Black Lives
Matter movement, you know?
That's a loaded statement, right?
Because it implies that
you're coming from a place
that is rooted in the opposite, rooted in,
as you just said, like in racism.
Yeah.
Maybe it's not on the surface,
but if you trace it back
you have those tendencies
and it's been baked
into your psyche and you've
got to scrape it out over time,
so there's a confession in there.
For real, yeah.
You know?
So that's why I applaud John.
John, whenever you say you
change your mind about something
there's all there is, it's
that level of humility to say,
especially on this topic that like,
"I was wrong about one of
the things that like ... "
You know, if you could just say
"I adopt, yes, I support
Black Lives Matter."
And you just say only
the positive, you know
maybe that's great, but to say,
"I'm coming to grips with
what I used to believe
"and I'm changing."
I think that humility is called for,
it has so much more of an
impact on others as well.
It's much more powerful.
I mean, listen, the
reason I put that article,
I wrote that article in
that way for two reasons,
one is I wasn't trying to be like,
"Hey, I'm an authority on this."
It was more like my
primary goal this year,
as it relates to these issues is just
to listen and learn, because I don't,
I'm not as well educated
and I don't have the personal experience
of people of color and
what they've gone through.
But the second thing was
this is the only thing that
might have been meaningful
and impactful to me in the
past is just hearing someone
that I could relate to talk
about these things, right?
And that's why I kind of wrote
the letter to my former self.
But this is a really difficult
thing to change your mind on
especially when you've got lots of people
in your community and
in the world, frankly,
who find all kinds of ways to
discredit the movement, right?
So it might be anything from like,
"Okay, well let me tell you
what Black Lives Matter did,
"Black Lives Matter was
responsible for violent, you know,
"riots or however you want to, you know?"
So saying that because there was violence
or that property damage or
whatever that took place
as in conjunction with the BLM protest,
therefore the underlying thing
that's being fought for is illegitimate,
and you can just write
the whole thing off.
Or you can mischaracterize the movement as
"This is just a Marxist
movement that's designed to
"completely rip apart the
fabric of traditional America
"and therefore I'm going
to, again, write off,
"I'm not going to entertain
any empathy for this
"and I'm not going to try to address
"the central issue that's
being talked about."
There's so many sort of
corners that you can crawl into
to avoid actually dealing with
the central issue of the
history of systemic racism
and the way that it
has morphed and changed
and gotten even more sort of conniving
in the more recent past
and not as obvious,
which makes it even harder to sniff out,
but it just takes,
honestly, it takes a lot.
It takes a lot for people to
experience this kind of change.
And we personally have a lot of empathy
for the people who are
resistant to that change
and are experiencing that change.
So, you know, again, like Link said,
kudos to John for sharing this,
because it's really the only way
that we can see real change
is the people who are
holding back the change
are actually experiencing the change.
And I just think that it's powerful.
And it just bears saying
again, because it's, you know
it might be easy for us just to say
all the positive things
and to say the right things
about the Black Lives Matter movement now,
because we are in front
of these microphones
and you could argue that
we have something to lose
by saying the wrong thing.
Yeah.
I hope you know that's not what's going on
and that we're, you know,
we're sincere about this,
but part of that is saying
we've had to change.
You know, I think that's kind
of the proof in it is saying,
"Well, it's not that I've always been
"on the right side of this.
"I've been, I was, you know,
"I grew up on the wrong side of this."
Yeah.
And so making that change
is nothing to brag about.
It's something that instinctively
I'd rather not talk about.
Yeah.
But again, that's why in general
we're championing people who
say, "I changed my mind."
Yeah.
Which implies that like John was saying
that 180 degree turn.
Well, and I think it's
significant that, you know,
he points out Michael Che
and Dave Chappelle, right?
And you know, both of
those guys tend to be
pretty polarizing figures
in their own right, right?
You take Dave Chappelle,
Dave Chappelle says a lot of things
that are offensive to a lot of people.
He tends to be a very
polarizing character,
but I find it interesting that
somebody like John would say,
"Well, you know, Dave Chappelle
was actually responsible,
"partially responsible
for me changing my mind
"about this central issue."
And I think, again, that goes to that,
this is not some clean process.
There's not just this, you know,
everybody who thinks right
about this is on this side
and everybody thinks wrong
about it is on this side.
And you have to be, you have
to talk about this stuff
and you have to be right
in every single way
that you talk about it.
And you have to be
super, super consistent.
When we insist on this
absolute standard of excellence
and complete wokeness
in order to accept people,
one of the things that we do is
we lose the ultimate mission,
which is not that we all just
think exactly the same way
and agree on every single thing
and have some standard that
we hold ourselves accountable to.
No, we've got a whole lot of people
that we're trying to move
in the right direction.
The goal is for all of us
to collectively get better,
and that you have to take
into account process.
Right.
And ethicacy, and I think
people might change.
I think, honestly, I'm
not saying that, again,
me saying that I think Dave Chappelle
has been a force for good
in this particular regard
as John is pointing out,
does not mean that I endorse
all of Dave Chappelle's comedy
or all of Dave Chappelle's perspectives.
But all I'm saying is
that I don't have to agree
with every single thing
that somebody does or says
in order to be able to say that
they've been a force for good
about this particular issue
and be like, "You know what?
"You did some good work
there and that's great.
"You changed somebody's mind."
That's what we're trying to do.
We're trying to change peoples' mind.
We're trying to, like you said,
become better as a collective.
We're not just trying to be like,
"Here's the fence between the two sides
"and I want to make sure that
"I keep putting up boards on that fence
"and make sure everybody's
over here on this side.
"And let's keep building that fence
"higher and higher and higher."
No, what we want to do is
we want to bring the
fence down lower and lower
and continue to bring
people over it, you know?
I would much rather be
friends with someone
who was not on the right side of an issue,
but demonstrated a
sincere open mind to it.
Yeah.
Than someone who believed
all the right things
and was firmly in the right.
If, you know, if you're
able to assess that by,
from any vantage point.
You know, it's just that
that's not, there's no grace.
That's not a reflection of
humanity and how, you know,
the human experience of, you know,
everybody's somewhere and
is not going to be right
about every everything.
And they're not ...
You're gonna be wrong about most things.
Everyone is going to be
wrong about most things.
It's easy to put it in the poetry example.
Again, you know, if
someone said, you know,
"I don't get poetry."
It's like, "You know what?"
And if I was a poetry scholar ...
You could have been.
Or let's say that's what I
was most passionate about.
Could have been.
It's not ...
You have glasses.
I'm with you, I don't get poetry.
But I just wouldn't,
I don't know that I would
want to converse with someone
who says, "You know, I hate poetry."
Right.
You know?
It's just ...
Versus I don't think I
understand poetry enough.
I hate jazz.
I don't think I understand poetry enough
to really appreciate it.
That's one way to say it.
You know what I mean?
And so, yeah.
And again, I think that we talk about,
we talk about these things
in a way that may be,
again, it's, what I am saying is
that I have empathy for
people who disagree with me
because I disagree with my past self.
Right.
It's as simple as that.
And I don't know, I get so frustrated
with the nature of dialogue
on both the left and the right,
because it's as if the goal
is to solidify the ranks
versus actually make progress
and move the collective
in the right direction.
And I don't know, I just feel like,
'cause we get into a place
where it's just like,
"Oh, that person said this
thing that offended me.
"And therefore every single
thing they've ever done
"or will ever do is illegitimate."
It's like, well,
I don't want to treat myself in that way.
I don't want to treat anybody in that way.
I wouldn't want to be treated that way.
Because I'm gonna be wrong.
I'm gonna say things that are wrong.
I have said things that are wrong.
I'll tell you something I was wrong about.
And it's this next one.
Okay.
Just to get, just to
lighten it up a little bit.
Rachel said,
"I insisted we would never
have pets inside the house.
"Then we got our cat and I insisted
"she'd never be allowed in the bedroom,
"but now both our cats sleep in the bed
"and I would kill a man if
either of them requested it."
Oh, wow, kill a man if
the cats requested it,
talk about a reframing of allegiance.
But I mean, yeah, for
years I was like, you know,
"I am not gonna have pets in the house.
"I am not, you know,
that's not who we are."
And then I came up with other reasons
to tell the kids why
it wasn't gonna happen.
But like, I just, you know, I
didn't like the idea of hair.
I didn't like the idea of the poop,
even if the poop was outside, I mean ...
You don't even want poop on the perimeter.
Every single time I'm just, you know,
doting over Jade or babying her.
You know, the kids still
love to point out like,
"Aren't you glad that you
were wrong about that?"
It's like, you know what,
and it's an opportunity
for me to say, "You know what?
"Kids, I'm glad that
you forced this issue.
"Lily, in particular, with the dog."
I'm gonna save any
conversation about the cat
that does live in our home
for a subsequent thing.
Yeah.
I will acknowledge that there's,
we now have a dog and a cat animal
living inside of our house.
Mm-hmm.
But I try to acknowledge.
Yeah, I take it as a moment to be like,
"Yeah, I am grateful that I
have done a complete 180."
Like my life is so enriched
and then I'll just start
gushing about Jade.
But really I see it as an opportunity to,
in an innocuous way, on an
innocuous topic, to say,
"You know what?
"I changed my mind."
I did change my perspective.
It wasn't about being
right or being wrong.
It's not about morality here,
but it's about humility.
Of saying, "You know what?
"I did change my mind and I
disagree with my former self.
"And my life is better because I changed
"than it was before."
And don't you think that's
really the heart of it?
Is the fact that when
you didn't have animals
in the house, the only
thing that you had to go on
was the perceived negative aspects
of having animals in the house, right?
It's like you can't
really perceive positives
without experiencing them,
but you can kind of anticipate negatives.
It's much easier, I don't know why,
it's just the way our brains work.
But then when you began to experience
the love that you can have for a dog,
which started, you know?
And a love that wasn't the
same kind of love that like
we had for our dogs growing up,
that like were like out in the shed
in the back kind of thing, you know?
They were more like, we
had just had like a wolf
that we happened to round up.
No, an inside the house dog that like
you receive this physical
love from on a regular basis.
Like your standards will
begin to change very quickly,
because you see the other
side of the coin, right?
And then you're like,
"Oh. there are going to
be some inconveniences."
I mean, one of the things
that I think about,
and we've talked about this is
when you decide to love something
then you start thinking
about the fact that
this thing is not, this thing
doesn't live as long as me.
Like this dog will die most
likely before I will, right?
If we both live to our
general life expectancy,
I'm gonna outlive Barbara.
And now I think about,
"Dang, that's gonna be really difficult."
But I'm still willing
to make the sacrifice,
because of the positive that
I'm experiencing right now.
It's really about, and too,
if you try to take that
and map it onto something that
is more moral, or, you know,
I don't know exactly know how you do that.
Like, how do you get someone to,
I think it goes back to what you said,
which is you got to make the
experience personal, right?
It's not something that you're just gonna,
you can't just sit and think
about the idea of a dog
in your house in your head
and come to some conclusion
to be like, "I love dogs in my house."
It's like, you got to have a
dog in the house, you know?
You gotta have a friend who
challenges your perspective.
You gotta see something in somebody.
You have to have a personal
experience in order
to change your mind about
something ultimately, right?
In your personal experiences it's with
having a dog in the house
and now a cat in the house.
And I'd much rather convey
that principle to my kids
than having all the
answers or being right.
It's being willing to be,
to admit when you're wrong
or when you've changed
your mind on something
that's not about right or wrong even.
Yeah.
It's more important than being right
at any particular moment, you know?
Because think about how miserable you'd be
if the only thing you
were doing was focusing on
continuing to bolster your
predetermined argument
that having animals in the house was bad.
I can imagine that there
are dads out there,
moms, brothers, sisters,
who I was dead set against
having a dog in the house,
and now that there's a dog in the house
I'm the person who doesn't like it
and I spend all my time pointing out
all the things that the
dog is doing that are bad.
Like what a miserable
existence versus accepting it
and staying positive.
Yeah, because then you're
like secretly petting the dog.
You don't want to be seen, right?
You have a secret relationship,
and then that gets weird.
You know?
Right.
Secret petting.
Well, you know, there's other ones,
but we're not gonna get to
them for the sake of time,
because ...
We'll do this again.
But the fact that we did
have such great responses
and we still want to continue
to encourage people to respond.
And you know, one of the things
that we were talking about
that I want to talk to them about,
I want to talk to you about is
if you've never responded
to a prompt on Ear Biscuits,
maybe that's because you
don't follow us on Twitter
or you're not the type
of person to respond
to just open ended questions
associated with this show.
On the internet.
Or on the internet in general.
But we want to invite you
to take a risk and do that.
So if you follow our
@Mythical Twitter account,
or our personal accounts,
we can try to do a better job of
re-tweeting those prompts as well.
But definitely if you
follow the @Mythical account
you can see every so often
when we post these prompts
like this one about,
"Tell us about when
you changed your mind."
We just want to hear from more of you.
We enjoy the familiar faces
and the familiar names
and you really get that
sense of community.
And so we're not complaining about that,
but we do think there's a
whole group of people who ...
Just kind of watching.
You know, I bet you're a thoughtful lurker
and we want to hear from
you on these topics.
And sometimes the questions are tough.
It might take a little
time to think about it,
but you don't have to answer immediately.
You can come back and we
usually give, you know,
at least a day where you
can come back and add to it
before we roll everything up.
Yeah, I mean, like Link said,
we definitely appreciate the folks
who always respond to the prompts,
but we are, you know, really interested
in hearing from people
who've never responded,
who might say,
"I created a Twitter account
just so I could respond."
So #EarBiscuits.
You can continue to talk about
what we talked about today,
but also be looking for that next prompt
that we're gonna put out
there to get your questions.
And now I'm going to give my rec,
'cause it's my week.
On Disney Plus, there's, you know,
you can search by all the
different brands that they own
like Marvel and Star Wars,
and it goes on from there.
And, you know, they're
doing a lot of things
where they're creating
content around content,
like behind the scenes series
for the Mandalorian series,
which is absolutely amazing.
So I got curious, and
I was looking around.
There's lots of that in Marvel,
the Marvel section as well,
but there's one show called Marvel 616.
And it's basically this concept of taking
principles around the Marvel properties
and just exploring these
like tertiary ideas
or behind the scenes type things.
They're all, each episode
is completely different,
and I've only watched one.
So I'm only recommending episode one,
which is about the Japanese Spider-Man.
Hm.
Now I have, I've had a tee shirt for years
that had Spider-Man,
and then it had Japanese
writing underneath it.
And I just thought it
was a cool tee shirt.
Well, it turns out there's,
Marvel licensed Spider-Man
over in Japan, too.
And then they created a
television show for Spider-Man
and it was entirely different.
It was, you know,
there was some emissary
who pitched it to Marvel.
And then, it's a documentary on
creating an alternate universe,
basically a Japanese version of Spider-Man
that is totally different.
Does he have a suit?
He looks the same, it's the same suit,
but he's, the action
adventure that he's in,
like it's not Peter Parker.
Well, that makes sense.
Right.
And he's not in New York,
but I mean, like he fights
robots, he like drives vehicles.
He still behaves like a spider,
and they talk about like
how they made the show.
And it's just absolutely fascinating.
Is this a one-off documentary or?
It's a one-off, just that
one, the one episode.
And, you know,
it's all of the people
who were involved in it.
They even talked to the
stuntman who were like,
there's this iconic tower in Tokyo.
I think it's called the Tokyo Tower.
I'm probably getting
all this wrong, but ...
Well, that's a good guess.
Well, I mean, they tell the
story of him showing up,
of the stunt man showing
up on one of his first days
and he puts on the Spider-Man costume
and then they just tell him, "Okay."
He's just showing up for
work to be Spider-Man
and they're like, "Climb the tower."
With no net, no safety mechanisms.
He free climbs this tower
and then they use that shot
in like the closing or
opening credits of the show.
I mean, you want to get your money's worth
if someone's gonna put
their life on the line.
But all the stuff this guy
would do, like they would,
they didn't have any
budget, but they would,
it was important that they
were like high-action.
What years are we talking about?
This is the '70s.
Okay.
And like, so he would fight
these gigantic robots,
because you had to have gigantic
robots in Japanese shows.
Right.
That's what all of them were.
So it's at every turn
in everything they do,
it's just splendidly
strange to us as Americans
who know our Spider-Man,
but because, you know, they
were able to separate things
and there was no internet.
And like, they didn't share shows.
And Marvel said,
"Do whatever you want with Spider-Man
"to make it work over here in Japan,
"but it can't leave Japan."
Right, and it could be
contained at the time.
And it could be contained.
And so now if you watch these clips,
it's just like bonkers to us
and the stories are equally bonkers.
So I would definitely recommend that,
Marvel 616 episode one.
Episode one, maybe
you'll watch episode two.
Thanks for joining us.
#EarBiscuits.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.